I'm making a choice I don't think it is
the correct choice but I've made a
choice hi guys it is Wednesday here on
it's grace or once over Wednesday or if
you haven't heard the news about Beyonce
and her sister Solange and jay-z how are
you been watching this video right now
because clearly you wouldn't have
internet access
long story short Solange fought jay-z
physically in an elevator after the Met
Gala last weekend there's surveillance
footage and she just went ham sandwich
on jay-z chilled like a human windmill
the arms and the legs were just like
like have you ever watched a child
having a temper tantrum and they
followed the floor like limp trial and
then you try and pick them up and they
just flail everywhere that's what she
was doing which he's actually very
similar to how I dance and there's a lot
of speculation about why exactly she you
got so upset I thought today I would
just give you some of my thoughts on why
I think Solange was so upset with jay-z
here are some hypotheses jay-z didn't
have an extra tamp that is a very
frustrating time she wanted to wear the
tuxedo that night and JC just wouldn't
let her have her quick moment he didn't
agree with her opinion that time travel
exists clearly it was an argument over
the fact that there are multiple
dimensions in our universe and that in
some other alternate dimension the
Solange there was having fine time with
jay-z so
disrupt the continuity of dimensions it
was a science debate
she just had to stretch yes for a mint
he took two minutes he asked for a mint
but he took two mints
her phone died just trying to explain
that her favorite band is the Dropkick
Murphys stupid
he thought glitter was a good movie she
has a new album coming out he
mispronounced her name so Langley
she was constipated he's just super
claustrophobic why couldn't they take
the stairs she thought they were at the
Met Gala men eating tiramisu event she
was all pumped to see men eat tiramisu
as fast as possible I would be upset too
so there are just a few of my hypotheses
unwise to lunch so lunged at jay-z in an
elevator will we find out the real
reason I don't know well that's him
hey guys don't forget it that camp
Takota merch is still available at
giftcard calm we have these awesome new
sweatshirts and t-shirts and i really
think that you should go take a little
tappy tap peek okay goodbye